the Olympics might happen every four
years but it's taken a hundred and
twenty four years for climbing to become
a part of it and that means Britain's
most successful climber Shana coxy now
needs to get to grips with the format it
still seems really strange to hear
people say that climbing is gonna be in
the Olympics and then to think about
being part of the Olympics as an athlete
is yeah it's so surreal I think climbing
was growing already and it was kind of
growing at this rate that I never
expected so with the Olympic
announcement that's kind of snowboard
that everybody knows what to do if
something goes wrong in recent years
climbing has undoubtedly grown in
popularity the film free solo sir Alex
Honnold scale a 3,000 foot rock face of
El Capitan in Yosemite without a rope
and without a haunts climbers at the
Olympics won't be reaching quite such
dizzy heights they'll focus on indoor
disciplines much like a triathlon first
up it's Shauna strongest event
bouldering which is climbing at
different angles not far from the
grounds then there'll be speed climbing
which is a set climb 15 meters tool and
a quickest to the top wins and finally
lead climbing is similar to bouldering
but it's higher up and so you use a
harness and a rope with climbing it's
not a sport where you directly compete
against anyone else I guess a little bit
in speed but in Boulder and lead it's
you in the wall Shaun the first fell in
love with the sports that's three years
old but it was only when she left school
that she made the tricky decision to
turn pro I applied for University got my
offers accepted I wanted to know that
was an option for me and then deferred
for a year and tried gave myself a year
to see if I could make professional
climbing work and yeah then I broke my
leg like I think three weeks after
decided to not go to university which is
not great timing but yeah it all worked
out in the end
Shawna has now won the bouldering world
cup twice and she's got her sights set
on a podium finish in Tokyo